ich zeige euch heute zwei Methoden wie
ihr zu Hause saftige burreg machen
könnt es macht wirklich keinen Sinn sich
Breg zu kaufen kümmern wir uns um die
Füllung ich habe hier Hirtenkäse den
werde ich einfach einmal mit der Hand so
ein bisschen zerkleinern s dass er
bröselig wird und wir ih später perfekt
in die Mitte streuen können in die
Füllung kommt außerdem noch petasilie
einfach runterschneiden Riese Salz
bisschen Pfeffer ein paar Chiliflocken
und damit wir eine schöne Masse bekommen
ein wenig Olivenöl jetzt vermengen
nehmen uns jetzt so ein dreieckiges
brekblatt ich glaub diese Art von brek
heißt zigarabrek so wie Zigarette weil
dies so Form hat und weil man so
einwickelt gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
von unserer Füllung in die Mitte Rollen
es oben drüber und dann drehen wir es
einfach ein Zack und zum Abschluss
nehmen wir ein bisschen von unserer
Eiermischung Pinseln die oben drauf und
dann hält es auch schön zusammen Nummer
eins ist fertig machen wir ein paar
weitere die brex sind vorbereitet jetzt
haben wir zwei Optionen entweder wir
geben sie in eine heiße Pfanne mit Öl wo
wir sie ausbacken oder wir geben ein
wenig Öl drauf und geben sie in den
Backofen hier sind die Breg aus dem
Backofen und hier die aus der Pfanne ich
glaube ich habe jetzt schon meinen
Gewinner gefunden